so your question's about can a woman
who's a party girl reform and be worth
dating so can you give me a little more
frame around that
can you hear marriage yeah okay um so
basically
let's say you got a girl and i i'm i'm
asking this because i think this is rare
very rare percentage of the population
that potentially happens let's say they
were a party girl
uh you know drugging and doing or
whatever when they were younger
20s to maybe 25 and then
got pregnant got married didn't work out
and just kind of focused on being a mom
and doing her thing and grew as a person
um better of her life i guess my
question is that what because
you talked about a chapter in that you
know plug alpha red flags
here's a red flag here's red flags red
flags or something at any point though
does a woman
can a woman reform not from the
hypergamy and the substance i know
that's all going to be there
but from the things that potentially
were red flags like she didn't have a
good relationship with dad
when she was younger has built a
relationship on that in her now i know
that there's probably some psychological
stuff that might still be there
but just you know can a woman work on
herself enough to become worth the
dating
yes but not a lot of women will
most will play the victim card victim
mindsets a lot easier
um it just that's just a route that they
that they'll tend to take more often not
but um
i mean i've dated women that have taken
ownership for some of their past choices
they can't do anything about stupid [ __ ]
they've done in their 20s like you're
talking about party girls you know
specifically if she was out partying
going to raves
doing drugs getting roofed you know like
our last caller was talking about
racking up a notch count um that's
that's part you know it's like you know
when you cut a tree down you see the
rings
and each ring you know each concentric
ring just builds off the other ring
it's just part of them right like women
with a
notch count that's greater than two or
three
in accordance with the studies that
we've seen don't make great long-term
monogamous choices or wife material or
mother stock
because of their past history and they
have a harder time bonding in a
monogamous healthy way to a guy
in a marriage so the chances of divorce
divorce rape all that kind of [ __ ] they
all go up
so yeah i mean you should try to
establish what her past is like i mean i
always say
women are concerned with your future
meaning you know like your ability to
provide what kind of resource
acquisition you know you can bring to
the household and all sort of stuff
but men in return need to be concerned
with her past
because you need to evaluate her and
what she brings stable
and what you're going to allow and
tolerate in your life because
if you're a guy worth anything you're
going to be spinning plates
and you're going to have options and you
might have this one smoke show hot chick
who has a peppered past and you might
have another one that's
not you know got all the boxes ticked
but she doesn't have a peppered pass
well if you're looking for wife stock
you know the one that's going to mother
the best children and be less likely to
screw you over
and grind you through the divorce
machine is probably the better choice
right so guys will complicate their
lives and justify why they'll make up
[ __ ] in their heads and i'm
i mean you you may very well do this
after the call right like you might say
you know what this check's hot doesn't
matter screw rich doesn't matter what he
says
i'll make it work i'm tom-tastic i got a
dope tie and a cool haircut i can make
[ __ ] work
right because that's what guys do right
you know we're like yeah you know we
like to problem solve
men are deductive reasoners we like to
problem solve so we like to take on
challenges
and um you know that's why the uh phrase
captain sabah is so popular
in the men's space because men like to
swoop in and it's like i can solve all
of her problems with my magical d
right i'm just gonna do this that the
other thing i'll solve it all it's like
no dude you can't erase you know those
concentric lines
in the tree trunk they're they're there
they're
part of her part of her dna there's
there's guys that that take it
farther than that even and they'll say
like oh well you know
uh there there's dna that's embedded in
her brain stem
and in her brain because of all of the
loads that she took and you know
is that really what you want i don't
know man like i've seen studies on both
sides of those
stories but some guys will just take it
and run with it but
at the end of the day like you're the
gatekeeper to the relationship so
be very very careful with who you invite
into your life because if you invite a
problematic woman
that that that has issues
rest assured they are going to show up
at some point in your future
i said at the start of the 20 red flag
chapter and again guys if you're just
logging in you can get that chapter for
free by hopping on my email list
right here um i said at the start of the
chapter i said you know
you can date these women you can make
them your girlfriend you can wife them
up and have babies with them
but i'm telling you right now you're
inviting an extra layer or several
layers of complexity into your life
if you do invite them into your inner
life so just be careful with that is
what i'm saying i get
this wasn't really more this is less
more i'm looking at dave this person
as just just wondering because
yeah but i think it's a rare occurrence
if you have i mean i think it's rare
occurrence of anybody in men
and women of taking ownership not
playing a victim
you know you're looking to have a hard
time finding a perfect girl
all women have some form of baggage it's
like
you can have it all you just can't have
it all in the same woman
so spin the plates let the cream rise to
the top
let the crap fall off to the side and
you know decide what it is that you want
to do and just make sure that
you're clear on what kind of life that
you want to lead and hold true to that
to that part of you right like if you're
if you're clear about
do do do like these like these key
points make sure that you don't deviate
from that
because you're not going to be able to
change things you know
many years into a relationship with her
right it's it's
something that you have to vet for from
the very beginning like you can't go and
order a brand new car from the
dealership
and you know it shows up and it's
ordered as spec and you're like
you know i should have got it in red
what am i gonna do
i mean you could wrap the car in a red
rap sure but i mean like you get the
idea right
yeah yeah absolutely yeah all right
thanks
good time
you